well this is normally the silly season
isn't it when Wessels swamped by stories
about kind of gay penguins and postpaid
plans but this year the world is blowing
up we've had Syria Iraq Iran Israel with
Gaza Russia Ukraine now talk of the
Taliban making ground in Afghanistan and
now I'm Libya so James what's going on
in in Libya there's been some pretty
catastrophic I don't you see is in Libya
the chaos that has been developing the
country post-gaddafi is worsening by a
day you've now got the situation where
rival factions are fighting over control
of Benghazi airport which is reducing
the amount of aid that can come into a
country and you also have a situation
why no even petrol stations won't open
and because it's too dangerous and if
you cut off petrol supplies to people a
country dries to a whole pretty quickly
yeah I think it's kind of revealing of
what's happened in Libya on Howard of
just how uncertain we are about what
what to do with these societies in the
Middle East so we go into Libya to stop
Gaddafi doing what he was doing in
support of the uprising the regime Falls
Gaddafi is hunted down and then killed
but we don't know what to do off do it I
think that what we're seeing in Libya
now is that question playing out as i
understand it with libya you know there
really was no game plan there wasn't a
thought but into what would happen
afterwards it was intendin itself
because I suppose you can't it's very
difficult to predict what's what's happy
we've gone into the situation of
stopping Gaddafi gain into Benghazi yeah
became the goal yeah um and also to
commend the game villeroy and so that
was done and that almost certainly did
stop a massacre but we then didn't we
learn one person of large amounts of
boots on the ground after us a try and
and pacify the country to drive help and
new government come into being and
everything has slipped back and then on
and what you're seeing is a dictator
keeps lots of tensions with a country
pent up and so all the tensions are
built up during get out
I'm now spilling out James what do you
think of the story that they're in The
Sunday Telegraph here that families may
sue Putin over there Jack why she's had
a good thing or was it um I don't know
whether this legally will work but i
think what is onto is that the only
thing that is intimated booted think
twice having personally in something
that affects him in his family he's down
one of the wealthiest men in the world
um his family all like to live overseas
and in one of his children lived in
holland she's had to leave her house
because of public outrage understand of
the dating it's more than 100 dr.
systems died in this plane crash on this
plane shooting down i should say so i do
you think that these sanctions will need
to be talked to that at Putin personally
to make him think twice I wonder legally
whether they'll be able to pull this off
now David and perhaps you can explain to
us this the story about fracking where
we're social sounds pretty exciting from
our point of view the new minister Matt
Hancock has been saying guess he wants
these fracking companies to come to you
know England and yes he wants door to
begin here and it's going to sweep away
sort of various problems actually
feasible as it just we play all the
planning rules and regulations and let
fracking happen well I think the latest
round of licensing is this a basin six
years
and it's a test of what the government
has already done to try to simplify the
planning situation say the environment
agency is trying to induce waiting times
for low risk assessments from 12 weeks
wars at 14 weeks yes 14 weeks to two
weeks so this round of licensing be a
test of whether that is successful or
not whether the environment agency can
deliver what is supposed to be do
moreover there are still despite all the
changes been brought in today I think by
my count 14 separate legislative acts
and regulatory directives both national
and international that applies each and
every English education that's a
cigarette burden of regulation if you
talk to people who will have a company's
rather who are trying to provide these
for a true drilling come for services in
the north or south of England they talk
about this burden to shrug their
shoulders a will just get on with it and
they recognize that it's actually quite
useful for them to halloween is blooped
to go through because it theoretically
defeats the green arguments against them
in terms of whether this can work I
think that as an application last week
and whisper green in West Sussex which
was denied on what one of the chief
reasons was that there was going to be
too much traffic later
hmm this highlights I think what the
major impediments are sharing isn't
brilliant the infrastructures and paper
promotion moving the roads and bridges
and all the roads and bridges and people
always talk about the Americans on key
distinction between America it's not
actually there sighs it's the
infrastructure in America you get
massive freight trains shipping movie
stuff to in from the fracking laws yeah
in brushtown you hook little spin become
transa remote the resumable be in the
middle of absolutely nowhere yeah so
contestable shale enthusiasts it as we
all are let's do you want it in your
village you prepared to have it in your
village